hey everyone welcome to simulation we
are currently at Athena health in Boston
with Jonathan Bush the CEO thank you for
joining us
hey it's a treat we appreciate it so
much yeah and it was great meeting you
yesterday at the radical wellness summit
lark fusion of David Ewing Duncan that
was a great time it was a good time he
is a he's a funny man but he definitely
knows how to give a good time yeah and
especially what a great group of people
that are kind of pioneering this AI
biotech push and you are as well
Athena Health's been around 20 years 21
almost unbelievable yeah I started in my
basement with a bunch of people and I
was worried that maybe I was lying to
them that it was a company but it's it's
worked out it's worked out really well
and we're really excited about the next
chapter twenty years later now you have
your own recording studio here you guys
are have a whole campus yeah how many
employees 5000 employees thousand about
a hundred and fourteen thousand
providers so thirteen percent of all
visits to the doctor happened on at the
internet about half of all doctors in
the country used at the internet once a
month at least once a month to look
something up and using Epocrates which
is a mobile app that's cool if you're a
doctor and so then your main products in
an electronic health record no there's
there's four there's four main products
Epocrates which is a mobile app for
clinical decisions okay a collector
which is our biggest revenue product
which is basically the billing that the
doctor and the hospital have to do with
insurance companies clinicals which is
the medical record and then communicator
which is a service for connecting
directly to consumers and giving them a
little more about dashboard with their
doctor so this is more of a futuristic
approach to health care we're hoping
that will be the first definitely the
first vert vert the first platform
company in medicine maybe the first
vertical platform anywhere I mean all
the platform comes as you see are these
very thin swath many many many consumers
but not many things to do kind of look
shop you know look shop shop look view
and what we're talking about
something that's much more involved and
most of what we're thinking about in
terms of our future plans involve
turning these incredible data assets
into platform utilities that will allow
other people to build other electronic
medical records and sell them on our
platform which will be a kick in the
pants to our fabulous fabulous EMR teams
we have a more more growing desire to
keep our own data secure but also to
give our data for better machine
learning so that we yeah so how what do
you think as we go towards a more open
source anything that you leave in a box
and never look at for really long time
or have very few people look at is you
know not as useful as you think it'll be
and our data is like that it's pretty
locked up siloed it's not reconciled and
so it sucks but because we're lucky
enough that Athene and have all of our
clients using the same instance of the
same application feeding the same basic
database environment we're in a position
to create data that's more useful that's
actually got information that doctors
and patients want to see that's kind of
where we are as a company we offered a
series of business services that help
doctors get more money faster and spend
less time doing crap work that is
bureaucratic and non clinical and we
still do that and we still get more
doctors every month but the exciting
work now is to take all that data and
take all those connections you know
we're the screen in the exam room we're
the screen we're the prescription pad
we're the appointment pad for the
patient to turn that into insight
moments yeah for people by joining all
these data sets into one yeah Knights
freaking awesome and will you be
collaborating with maybe Amazon as they
dive into this so we want to build an
open platform this is the all the API is
for all the new utilities that we're
building an Athena are open people can
build on our stack new Amar's new apps
and and certain even our clients can but
but entrepreneurs can there's 200
companies that are attached to Athena
net
selling products that make life better
for doctors and patients so very much
the goal is to open up these silos we
don't want to be the next monolithic
monopoly you know to unseat the old ones
we want to actually end that notion
yeah and create a really really really
broad-based kind of flower garden of
wild and domesticated species yeah and
health really needs that it really does
you know all the best intentions right
we created a kind of a trap at our
Rapunzel type Tower for our health care
you had to go all the way through this
locked tower
can only be accessed through third-party
paid highly highly highly brittle
products you know the product and
medicine is one of 8,000 cpt codes I
don't remember what CPT stands for
something procedure transaction item but
literally you can't do the kind of
product management that all of us in in
in in modern consumer generations expect
you know grab the software grab that now
let's grab the work bundle it together
and turn it into a ride or a meal yeah
right or your laundry or yeah or your
health but because healthcare is kind of
siphoned a cordoned off it's been very
hard to get that kind of product
management going yeah and we hope that
by opening this stuff up using really a
set of services that cater to the old
world Madison I mean everything we do
most of our big revenue products cater
cater to old-world medicine because our
mission is to bring the docs that sign
up with us across the bridge into the
new world and help them profit by a form
of medicine that people like more so
what are your thoughts as we more and
more people are understanding that holy
cow I'm going in I might get treated but
the treatment might not work this is
more based on effort than it is based on
outcome and so how do we transition more
to an outcome
yeah well health care product management
right is is the idea of saying you know
we're not happy
no you're not until you're happy and
crazy Eddie's or you know if you don't
like your LL Bean boot turn it in at any
time then we'll give you a new pair
right that is that idea that they're
essentially providing insurance in a way
right they're ensuring their sneaker or
their stereo or their boot and in health
care we don't do that we just run you
through again yeah
and that fundamentally flies in the face
of what an American consumer really any
human soul yeah wants from someone that
they're at the mercy of and in the
market it particularly calls people who
are in the mercy at the mercy of someone
in the market and medically weak right
you're you're there occasionally because
you're actually sick and that
combination makes that that the
non-existence of product guarantee of
product management of what you called
what results based or outcomes based
yeah medicine particularly frustrating
and you think that the tools that you
can build here with athenahealth yeah
doctors don't know what happened to the
patient's they treat how often when I
use this drug how often does the patient
end up at the hospital versus that truck
versus no job versus maybe an exercise
app yeah these choices the the data
behind these choices is anecdotal at
best even clinical trials are pretty
freakin weak right we don't know a lot
of detail we don't really run a ton of
people through them I mean they meet
ethical standards that are high compared
to not doing them and there's nothing
wrong with the people doing them so then
we need to have an actual breakdown of
what a patient gets prescribed to do and
then the efficacy of that is that times
a million and buy exactly and by the way
some one guy might be at the hospital
more often and love it another guy might
not but I hate it
that's relevant to right if patient if
patients just loves plan a and hate Plan
B but plan B is cheaper you know in a
sophisticated world you might say well
you know Medicare's not paying for plan
a plan B because it's sorry Medicare is
not playing for panic cuz it's more
expensive but you love it
but here's the chart here's the price of
the difference for 20 bucks you can
choose plan a which you like more and is
more money and suddenly there's some
tourism in there suddenly there's the
possibility of the person getting the
service being powerful over the service
as we progress into more artificial
intelligence and more of these augmented
technologies and a lot more of that
control comes in to the power of the
home and into the power of the patient
where do you need this even more right
if we took all the data the doctors have
believe me we're trying and we just did
a big we're in beta with Apple right now
where you can take all the data that we
have and pull it up into your health kit
on your iPhone in fact we just had a
company meeting and some kid actually
drove out and got a wellness visit out
of one of our clients in Western Mass
that's one of the beta sites so that she
could pull up her own chart in her
iPhone and then she did it for us at the
company meeting it was awesome but the
that sort of government coded very
brittle
sort of data that is not yet information
that makes up a chart isn't gonna be all
that exciting for a consumer to see but
by making it available hopefully like I
said earlier some product management
could kick in where we could look I mean
if you saw weather buoy data or you know
Airport weather beacon data it looks
like crap and no one would look at it
but once NOAA and the FAA made those
feeds available we have Weather Channel
we have a thousand apps their graphical
their fun and everybody's aware of the
weather it's just a different the
opportunity to let product managers in
to work with data and try different
approaches just completely civilize is
it we started this interview with the
idea of you know something that's
sitting in a box that never gets looked
at you know it's not what you remember
it was in there and healthcare data is
that way today
so wouldn't then you need to be a vital
part of the patient at home then in some
way we hope that you know docs on Athene
and it will have all of the early
engaged patients
the apps that we give Doc's to give to
their patients are the kinds of things
that you know rational awake consumers
are gonna demand and that our Doc's will
be the ones that are easiest and most
wonderful to deal with and then what do
you what would you say is the best way
to describe healthcare to the future
generation you know I think radical
wellness is a pretty good way of
explaining it I think that there's
probably going to be this base kind of
break fix apparatus that doesn't go away
and carry some extra weight that that we
don't need but it'll be there for a long
time but I see a layer coming
an intelligent layer that yeah those
were interested can tap into and
dramatically change their experience of
medicine the cost of it but also the
humanity of it my biggest deal of
medicine is not how expensive it is it's
really expensive but we're a really rich
country the problem is that for all that
money that huge amount of money more
than your house in your car combined
it's not really an expression of our
humanity you can't trick it out and like
meet anyone at the bar with your
healthcare choices and like get
connected and for all the money and
resources Arkell into it it should be
part of who we are we should be able to
trick it out our way exactly and that's
what I hope we enable and I think
technologies like AI parsing biometrics
as well as blockchain technology for
security purposes and then access
control for everybody might even be able
to get paid for our data Universal basic
income potentially could youcould sure
you could do that I mean that data is
just a record of what happened so it'd
be hard to tell a doctor you can't have
a record of what you did but regardless
of whether we still have a very
old-world notion of data like that
there's all this money in it because
we're so blind we're so we're so siloed
as these silos come down the idea that
data is worth money is going to be as
obsolete as the idea that software with
no services are value-added is
with money we don't buy enterprise
software products anymore nobody's
bought a CD in years but the data it
will be worth something as me I think
the information that people tap off the
data will be worth a lot more though
yeah the rows and columns themselves
sure yeah yeah actually making sense of
the data
definitely what are your thoughts about
the current platform and what is
actually ideal how do we balance out
innovation and creativity with these
capitalistic incentives along with kind
of a more social fabric net that is good
for people yes yeah yeah well it's a
really interesting question it is the
fundamental question of medicine is that
the the thing that makes health care so
expensive to the average person and so
unaffordable and so inhumane is directly
caused by society's desire to protect
people who are vulnerable so by
protecting people who are vulnerable
were screwing people who are vulnerable
it's a weird right because by by by
making everybody have access to an
all-you-can-eat buffet of every course
then nobody has to make their product
cheaper in order to get it to more
consumers yeah because by law every
consumer has to have unlimited amounts
of it you got to keep the fire burning
under people's butts yeah yeah so
there's no fire burning so you know when
you go to a hospital I mean everybody's
gone and like Jesus who runs this place
like how can this be so dumpy and
disorganized and it's so unique the CEO
you know she's a great woman or whatever
the docs are great the staff great but
somehow there's nothing that just
flushing the waste out of it why are
they so big why are there so many common
spaces that are underutilized why is 58%
of the equipment idle and lying around
it's just weird
right but by the same token you know it
would be hard to just pull the rug out
from under people and say hey no social
safety net so it's a dance we're working
on an edge surfing you know how do we
get in there and find a spot where
there's enough demand curve there's
enough shopping that waste is getting
flushed and new ideas are being brought
forward yeah but people aren't totally
screwed when a tractor hits them in the
yard yeah okay this is
very you're right we're figuring it out
it's very tough and that's why we like
to ask people like you literally at the
forefront of these industries well I
hope yours come and work here and solve
the freaking problems I think I think I
think from what we've seen is an
incredible place to be and to be around
other brilliant people are trying to do
so here folks you heard it here here's
how about a quick question about what do
you think's the most beautiful thing in
the world joy is the most beautiful
thing in the world and joy is for me
this notion of setting out on impossible
noble missions with people you love yeah
it's not about pleasure it's not about
success facts the present success can be
depressing is like now what do we do
yeah it's that setting out that I think
we can step there and how might we get
there and all right I'll lean on you
over here but then you'll pop me up over
there and you know then we'll both duck
down and crawl through here and that
whole working together to get to
something bigger than ourselves to serve
something bigger than ourselves that's
that's everything to me that is an
incredible answer we love that mission
and passion value of waking up in the
morning and having some sort of an
adventure looking forward to with other
people that brings value to the world
that brings something makes the world
better for generations to come
I'm glad that that's also something that
you bring up there resonates with you
it's a beautiful thing in the world gets
me up in the morning awesome Jonathan
Bush day hey thank you guys appreciate
it it's been such a pleasure enjoy the
campus